commencez vous monsieur de la fuite des
capitaux je trouve ça beau minables des
hommes comme monsieur
comme monsieur
monsieur
n'ont pas fait le métier qu'ils auraient
dû faire et ils l'ont démontré dans les
élections c'est pour cela qu'elle aura
actuelle les gens ont peur et cette
confiance ne paye commis que par un seul
homme qui à l'heure actuelle est capable
d'ordonner le courage aux françaises
c'est monsieur pense que c'est un peu
tardif quoi parce que je pense qu'il ya
eu une grosse grève qui avait été
décrétée en bourse et je me suis rendu
compte que le lendemain les patrons vous
avez lock outés les capitaux eu le temps
de fuir à cette époque là maintenant que
tout le monde s'alarme en dix ans les
capitaux fuient à l'étranger je trouve
que c'est la progression quoi de la
dégueulasserie
excuser ce geste en apparence obscène
mais la france ayant arrêté dimanche
dernier secoué d'un léger frisson à
gauche nous avons voulu savoir si sa
bourse avait la fièvre
[Musique]
dans un dernier sursaut de patriotisme
capital à son tour mais son argent à
gauche
[Musique]
tous les moyens sont bons pour
dissimuler vos capitaux
[Musique]
comme tout mauvais français vous
disposez d'un compte numéroté en suisse
comment faire parvenir votre argent à ce
compte secret bien vous et montez votre
combiné vous introduisez des pièces de
monnaie à l'intérieur puis vous faites
sur le cadran le numéro de votre compte
[Musique]
alors la banque de genève ici le comte
1456 à vous est tout simplement votre
argent est arrivé
financier attristé sauver votre capital
[Musique]
un
panini étrangers au capital est à l'abri
[Musique]
tous les moyens sont bons pour faire
passer sans difficulté la frontière à
vos lingots
[Musique]
bono
en
france
[Musique]
en réalité tout cela n'est qu'une
apparence le français d'un bon français
et tout ce bel argent retourne au
bercail
[Musique]